[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Welcome, everyone.
We are so excited to
host Gonzalo Guzman, chef
and partner of
Nopalito restaurant,
and his co-author of
the beautiful Nopalito
book, Stacy Adimondo.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you, [? Elia. ?]
So first question
I have is I want
to know what was your
first exposure to cooking.
GONZALO GUZMAN: When I met
actually Chef Laurence, chef,
owner of Nopa right now.
So I just came to his
kitchen, and just started
seeing a bunch of
things going on.
And they were all just
pretty attractive to me,
so I just decided that that's
kind of what I wanted to do.
Because before that, I just
started working in restaurants.
It was just a job.
It wasn't something
that I wanted to do
or something that
was in my head.
But after seeing
all that, I realized
that that's something
that I kind of wanted
to take serious and start--
yes, start taking more serious.
And just start cooking and see
where that was going to go.
SPEAKER 2: Did you have
previous experience before that?
GONZALO GUZMAN: No.
I started as most people
when they first come here,
washing dishes, which I
did in another restaurant
for like probably
a couple of months.
And then they put me right
away into a prep station,
and then a few months
later, I was line cook.
And then I started
working all the stations
in that restaurant,
and that's kind of how
I learned what I now know.
STACY ADIMONDO: One thing that's
pretty neat that Laurence,
the co-owner of Nopalito, says
in his introduction to the book
is that a lot of
Mexican immigrants
had come through his kitchens.
And not all of them fall
in love with cooking.
And he said he really
saw something special
in Gonzalo, in
that from day one,
he had wide eyes and
a lot of curiosity.
And he was really
excited to get into it
as a career and
a lifetime thing,
rather than just
a quick way to get
himself settled in the
country and make some money.
So that was, I think,
what inspired Laurence
to kind of say, I'm going to
keep this guy around and teach
him a few things.
GONZALO GUZMAN: And
I was also raised
by my mom and two
sisters, so all women.
So I kind of had to--
since I was little,
I remember doing all these
things that normally are just
for women in Mexico.
The place that I was
born in, South Mexico.
So, again, growing
in that kind of--
seeing all these-- the
way my mom was preparing,
and going into the garden and
picking all these vegetables
and all that, it was in my--
I guess, in my life already.
So it's not somebody
that I wanted
to do forever at that moment.
But then it's always been
with me since I was--
since I remember.
SPEAKER 2: So is
that kind of how
you developed your
style of cooking,
is through cooking with your
family and all that stuff?
And then you got more trained
when you came here and started
working in restaurants?
GONZALO GUZMAN: Yeah.
After like 10 years, I guess,
before we opened Nopalito,
I worked in so many
different restaurants here
in San Francisco.
But in the back of
my head, I always
had that idea of doing something
with Mexican food, which
that's the food that
I was raised with.
But always doing everything
that way I was raised with too.
And what I mean by
that is we will dry--
or plant our own
corn and dry it.
And then we will cook it,
and then we will grind it.
So pretty much everything
from scratch, and that's
kind of what I wanted
to do if I ever
will do Mexican food
or a Mexican-based kind
of restaurant.
STACY ADIMONDO: I also
think one of the baffling
things about making Nopalito
work from the beginning
was that he had such a
high standard of that.
It wasn't just, we're going
to grab tomatoes and make
a fresh tomato salsa,
because everybody expects it
to be at a Mexican restaurant.
He sort of thought, well,
tomatoes aren't in-season,
so why would I use
them in the salsa?
So they kind of operate the
same way that they would--
that Gonzalo did when
he was growing up.
Where, literally,
what was around
was chopped down off a tree
or picked out of the ground.
And that was the way
they liked to cook,
and it was a way that
made sense to cook.
So I think he's maintained
that in Nopalito,
but at such a large scale.
They have two restaurants.
How many pounds of masa come
out of the kitchen every day?
GONZALO GUZMAN: Between
both restaurants,
I think we do between 200 and
300 pounds of corn every day.
STACY ADIMONDO: And it's all
organic corn, if possible,
grown locally in
California and outside.
That's a serious undertaking
to even find that much product,
and do that by hand
just to start the day.
That's with every single
element of the Nopalito cooking,
is something that's
grown in-season,
locally, and the
best possible product
that they could've found.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, and there's a--
your appetizer,
the garbanzo beans.
You said they was traditionally
done with peanuts, but--
GONZALO GUZMAN:
Well, again, just--
it's funny.
I grew up in a really,
really small community.
400 people.
No electricity, no
water when I was there.
So again, my dad and
my mom, sometimes when
they wanted to spend some
time in the family together,
they will just fry some
peanuts from our fields.
And they will just fry
them with chili and lime,
and that was kind
of like our dinner
sometimes, because
there was nothing else.
But that's kind like the
idea of the garbanzos came.
And also because we wanted to
offer something to the guests
when they will first
arrive to the restaurant.
We didn't want to do
chips and guacamole,
or salsas that most Mexican
restaurants or taquerias
do here.
We wanted to give it more like--
original, I guess.
The way I was raised,
but also give something
to kind of start
water their mouth
and start ordering
more drinks too.
I was still--
STACY ADIMONDO: And
the peanuts were
very difficult to find
organically in the quantities
that they wanted.
So he thought, how do I get
creative with something that
does make sense year-round?
And so he picked
chickpeas, fried
like as to mimic that crunchy,
little nutty kind of snack.
GONZALO GUZMAN: So
my idea is different.
SPEAKER 2: So you've
mentioned restaurants
you've tried when
you first moved here,
and you even just did air quotes
to signify Mexican restaurants.
What was your first thoughts
about Mexican restaurants
when you first moved?
GONZALO GUZMAN: To me, I
thought it was Mexican food,
but for a bunch of
other Mexican people.
Because the way I
was raised, again, it
was totally different of what
I saw here in restaurants.
Like corn tortilla tasted like
plastic to me, to be honest.
I was used to really
tasting the corn.
I was used to taste
the ingredient.
Something that I felt like
I couldn't really find here,
I will go to taquerias
or restaurants.
And I will order
this sope, which
is pretty similar to
a traditional dish
that my mom will do when I
was little, called picadita.
About the same idea, but
usually they're thin and--
thicker than a tortilla, but
thinner than the sope tortilla.
And when I first
tasted that, because it
was the closest that I could
remember to my hometown,
I didn't like it at all.
It was really doughy and it
didn't really taste like corn.
It taste like
Play-Doh or something.
So again, I just went
between restaurants
and I just couldn't
really find anything
that I felt like it
was Mexican food to me.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So you
had a long process
of actually becoming Head Chef
of Nopalito and all that stuff.
I do want to read something,
because I do love your book.
And you said, "Mexican
food, at heart,
is a labor-intensive
style of cuisine
from a hardworking people."
So how did you get
to where you're
at from where you started?
GONZALO GUZMAN: You hear
these people saying,
work smarter instead of harder.
But I think if you combine
those two, you just kind of like
rush everything in a good way.
And to me, it was
like working hard.
Like working two
jobs in the morning,
at night, because I
knew I couldn't really
go to culinary school.
And first of all,
because I didn't
speak any English at all.
And second of all, because I
had to pay back a lot of money.
But I also wanted to learn more
different type of cuisines,
and that's why I went back
and forth between restaurants.
Because I felt like that
was kind of like, I will--
that was my way to
just learn something
that I wasn't able to learn
from not going to school.
So I was working always really
hard, but at the same time,
I was also taking some ESL
classes at city college
here just to learn the
language as much as I could.
Because I felt like it
was really necessary
if I wanted to be
more than just a cook.
I can always be a
cook, and I think
there are really, really good
cooks, even better than me
maybe out there.
But their challenge is the
language, and most of them
don't take that time
to go out there and try
to learn the language, which you
definitely need to communicate
with a lot of people.
So that's kind of how
I became what I'm now--
people say I am.
But it's just by working hard
in a smart way, and just--
so far, so good, so we'll see.
SPEAKER 2: Well, you also said
that the cookbook and Nopalito,
the restaurant itself, is an
attempt to remember and honor
the way things were from--
I'm guessing you meant
your childhood in all that.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Yeah.
It goes back, again,
to the same idea.
Everything from scratch
and not taking shortcuts.
And that's kind of
how the restaurant is.
Masa, but it's not just the masa
that we make in the restaurant.
And I think that's probably
the only Mexican restaurant
maybe in San Francisco still.
I'm not quite sure, but
that we grind our own masa
and we do the whole process
that a lot of people don't do.
Their food is really good, some
of the Mexican restaurants,
but I think they still take all
the shortcuts that I was raised
not taking those shortcuts.
And that's kind of
what I meant by saying
that you wake up in the
morning, you grind your own--
I mean, you cook your
corn the day before then.
I remember waking up, getting
this molino, that you now have.
And then grind
this masa and then
pass it through
the metate, which
is another piece of equipment.
And then to get it really
fine and make the tortillas.
It's all these steps
that I feel like we do it
at the restaurant on
a different scale.
Queso fresco, we will
make our own queso fresco.
Churizo or things like that
that we do at the restaurant,
that if I was doing it at
home when I was little--
Not anymore, because
now they all buy it.
Because things change, and it's
been 20 years almost since I--
now there is electricity, and
there is water, and all that.
But I am trying to keep that
idea, and just on a different--
in a city.
Which makes it a
little hard, but I
think that's the challenge that,
hopefully, people appreciate.
Again, that's what you
can find in the book.
You can make it as complicated
as you want it to be,
or as simple as
you want it to be.
You can just buy tortillas.
You don't have to
make your own masa.
But just so you see
it there and see
how much work it takes
to do a tortilla,
and appreciate more what
we do in the restaurant.
STACY ADIMONDO: And
this goes back to--
I mean, one of the first
stories Gonzalo told me
when I met him was about a
typical day in their family
life when he was growing up.
So his family owned
cornfields, and they'd walk,
starting at 5:00 in the morning
before the sun got too hot
and it was just
impossible to do anything.
Walked to the cornfields,
tend the cornfields,
dry all the corn by
themselves from in the fields.
Take it back, and then
there was one corn grinder
in his town of 400 people,
his village of 400 people.
So this was not only a
ritual, but literally
like pure sustenance
for them, where
every dish was based off masa.
Corn was just-- Gonzalo
says in the book,
and I love this line, is that
he feels like he wouldn't feel
like a Mexican if there wasn't
corn in his house at all times.
GONZALO GUZMAN: And it's true.
At home, I always have
masa or tortillas,
because I need to
have some of that.
I grew up with it, and it's
part of my life already.
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah,
and I think just
to think about taking
a shortcut, for him,
is just absolutely insane.
And I think, in
some ways, it takes
a little bit of convincing
for the average person.
The first time you hear about
the process of making masa
from scratch, you're like,
I would love to do that.
And then you're like, oh,
there's a lot of stuff to that,
and I'm not sure I can really
fit that into my weeknight.
But something that I learned
in the process of making
the book with him is
that it is a ritual,
and it's something that's
actually very simple at heart
and not difficult to learn.
And once you kind of
get used to having
that as part of
your pantry, as part
of your staples of
cooking in your kitchen,
you make a big batch on Sunday
night and then that's that.
And you have it to use
in any number of ways
throughout the week.
And the way that I think
it's used in Mexico
is so eye-opening.
It's not just to press into a
tortilla and serve as a taco.
We have a whole section
on masa in the book,
and I work for a magazine
called Saveur that focuses
on international cuisine.
And we ended up doing
a six-page story on--
actually I have it with me.
We did a six-page
story that ended up
you know putting masa
on the cover and inside.
And everybody sort of thought,
is there really that much
to say about it?
And there is.
It's like all the different
types of corn that you can use.
All the different ways
that you can use it
beyond tacos or quesedillas,
the words that everybody
is sort of familiar with
with Mexican cuisine.
You can use it to thicken soups.
You can use it to make a
number of antojitos, that
are the Mexican streets foods.
Gonzalo says that they used
to fry little nuggets of it,
kind of like gnocchi,
and just pop them
as snacks and [INAUDIBLE].
GONZALO GUZMAN: It's kind of
like the base for anything
you can imagine.
And it's just,
again, like Play-Doh.
You can make anything
or any figure you want.
So same thing with masa.
You can even eat
it as a dessert.
There is a recipe that
didn't make it to the book,
but it's a drink that is base
of masa, water, and sugar.
A specific sugar.
But, again, it's kind of like
if there is nothing else to it,
I think you will
survive with just masa.
That's how I see it, and
that's why it's so- to me,
it's so important
to have it with me.
But, again, it's
also for you guys
if you wanted to play with it.
Have some masa and start
playing with things,
and you'll see you'll survive.
SPEAKER 2: The
cookbook's laid out
to where you start
off with the basics,
like, here's the groundwork
that you need to know
about getting into this.
Like, first up, right up
here's what you got to know.
Then let's build from there.
I think masa-- is that one
of the first things in there?
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah, I
think it's pretty much one--
Well, after we kind of
introduce who Gonzalo is
and what Nopalito
is all about, we
go right into the wonderful
world of masa, essentially.
And just talking
about how to make it,
what it meant to him, his
stories about growing up
that we touched on, and all the
different ways that it's used.
And then we kind of
expand that into a section
on the Mexican pantry,
which to me, was
one of the most eye-opening
things of the exploration
process of learning with him.
Is that there are a lot
of unexpected ingredients
that I don't think many
people would associate
with Mexican right off the bat.
Even just in the spice cabinet,
you might think of cumin,
but you wouldn't necessarily
think of cloves, or anise,
or marjoram, or all
these beautiful, musty,
and deeply-flavored
spices that go
into things like moles, and
sauces, and chili paste,
and braised meats.
So all of a sudden, once
you start noticing that,
you taste the cuisine
very differently.
You take a bite of
something and you
think like, wow, this actually
has so many layers of flavors.
Those spices are toasted
and then they're ground.
And then there are a number--
we have a whole section
on dried chilis in the book.
Because I think if you
think of Mexican cuisine,
you think of jalapenos,
poblanos, serranos, maybe.
But those are the fresh, green
versions of these chilis,
and so many of them
are smoked, dried.
They come in so many
different flavors.
If you walk into a Mexican
market in San Francisco,
you'll see, literally,
a wall of dried chilis
that were treated
in different ways.
Have different spice
levels, different sizes.
And all of a sudden, it opens
up this entire other section
of salsas, chili
paste, and you just
begin to see how deep the
nuances of all of the pantry
staples and the spices run.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Which, again,
sounds very complicated,
all that.
I know.
But as I said, you can make
it as complicated as easy.
There are some recipes
that they're just
tomatillo and a chili,
and that makes a salsa.
STACY ADIMONDO: Right
GONZALO GUZMAN: And probably
start exploring with that one,
and then just change the chilis
and using the same tomatillo
ingredient or tomato,
just to get familiar
with the ingredients.
And if you love Mexican
food, you'll love it.
You'll love all these flavors,
and you'll start adding, little
by little, some other chilis.
And why not maybe even
doing the masa if you wanted
to explore a little bit more.
But it's definitely for people
that really enjoy cooking
and want to take that risk.
STACY ADIMONDO:
Gonzalo, when I was sort
like, oh, I'm never going to
remember all these chilis.
Where do I even start?
How do I know the
differences between them?
He said, after a
while, it becomes
like walking through
the grocery store
and looking at the potato bins.
You know the difference
between a sweet potato
and a white potato and what
not, and he's like, it just
becomes second nature.
You just see them, and
you're like, right, right.
Puya, arbol, this and that.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Takes time,
just like every cuisine.
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So with all
this different types
of masa and the
different chilis,
what was your thought
process like in what
recipes to put in the cookbook?
GONZALO GUZMAN: I think I
tried to pick the ones that
were much easier, I guess.
And some of them--
I don't know.
I mean, there is so many that
it was hard to pick through
like all these recipes.
Because that's probably
they have all the recipes
that we still have
in the restaurant.
But I think at the
end, whatever we
felt like people will enjoy it
more and will have more of--
have access to ingredient-wise.
Because there are some
recipes that definitely--
I'm not even able to
do it in the restaurant
because I don't have
the ingredients.
And if I do get them, I
don't get them as much.
Like if I get some specific
chili from Mojacar,
I probably will do a
small batch for my house.
So yes, we're a
staff mill because I
know people won't be able to
do it here with what we have.
So we kind of picked
through the recipes just
based on what people will
have more access to here.
Now you go to Mission St.
and you can get a bunch of--
all these ingredients that
you'll see in the book,
you'll find them there.
And that's what the whole
idea, just to make it--
STACY ADIMONDO: I
think a lot of them,
too, ended up being
the recipes that--
well, at least I thought Gonzalo
sounded the most sentimental
about and the most
nostalgic about it.
He'd sit up straight in his
chair, and he'd be like,
oh, my mom used
to do this, and I
couldn't stop eating
it right off the stove
as she was cooking.
It seemed like they
were almost the--
like the things he missed
about home the most.
And also the things
that I think would
give the most wide range of
understanding of the cuisine.
Like there's probably a
million different versions
of a quesedilla, but
we included three
or four thinking, per season,
there's one there for you.
These show a couple of
different techniques.
different styles of filling.
They're maybe from a
different region in Mexico.
So we give a little
bit of variety,
but obviously you
could barely scratch
the surface of what's out there
to learn about the cuisine.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Yeah,
being masa is still
the base of everything.
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah
SPEAKER 2: So besides on of my
favorite quotes, "Don't panic,"
what should people know
going into the book Nopalito?
GONZALO GUZMAN:
Well, they should
know that they're getting into
something that is probably--
I mean, for some people
it may be easier,
because they're more
used to, again--
they live in a
city where I think
there is a lot of Mexican
food, good or bad,
but still the idea is there.
I think you going
to open something,
you're not going to be afraid
what you gonna find in there.
Again, go and don't freak out.
Just go and look at the
recipes or the ingredients
that you're familiar
with, and try
to play around with those two.
And little by little, just--
don't read the whole
book, probably.
Start with two or
three pages first,
and then take some time to kind
of get into your head recipes
and steps.
And then little by
little, just keep
adding it to your-- just
like everything else.
STACY ADIMONDO: I think a lot of
times when people read recipes,
they think they can't
veer off of exactly
what's in the recipe.
And that if they do one part,
they have to do all 10 parts.
What's wonderful
about Mexican cuisine,
and slightly intimidating
about some of the recipes,
is that there are
so many layers.
So you start by toasting
a lot of ingredients
or frying some chilis, and
then you might grind something.
And then you might add
a sauce, and then you
might have to work
with the masa.
In the end, it seems like,
of course, a tostada.
So simple.
But really, the work that it
takes to get to some of them
is slightly challenging.
It takes some time, but
you can break that down,
and you can say,
man I really loved
you know that braised
chicken tinga that
goes on top of a tostada.
And by the tostada
shell, make the chicken.
Or if you really
loved a salsa that
came with one of
the dishes and it
was mixed in with
shredded beef, you
can mix it in with shredded pork
and adapt a lot of the things
that you learned from the book.
So I'd probably give the
advice, because there's
cooks of all
different walks, just
to feel free to take
little sections of it,
improvise off of
it, make something
slightly spicier or slightly
less spicy if you don't like it
that way.
If you're totally obsessed
with one style of dish,
then just go on your own
journey with that style
once Gonzalo kind of gives
you the confidence to--
the base level.
GONZALO GUZMAN: And keep
in mind that the first time
that you do something,
it almost never
will turn out the way you
wanted it to turn out.
It takes some practice,
and that goes with me
too whenever I'm trying and
some new dish that I kind of--
I've seen it before in
Mexico, or I want to do it.
It takes me two, or
three, or four times
until I get it the
way I wanted it to do.
So I know in the pictures
it always looks nice,
and when you do it, it
doesn't look just the same.
But I think that
just keeping in mind
that that's going to be almost
the case with any cuisine,
I guess, when you
try something new.
So just don't be
afraid to not get it
right the first time,
and the second time,
and the third time, or
maybe even the fourth time.
It's just like
everything, practice.
The recipes are there just to
guide you through the process.
But again, there's some
techniques here and there
that you can have to
develop yourself as you
practice with what recipe.
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah.
We have a joke in the preface
of the book about my first time
frying the salsa, which who
knew that that was even a thing.
But you dump hot
salsa into hot oil,
and you can guess what happens
if you choose the wrong pan.
My entire backsplash
in my kitchen
was like Jackson Pollock
from salsa a couple of times.
GONZALO GUZMAN: The
trick is not to stop.
Just put everything.
Don't stop right there, because
that's when the-- you know.
STACY ADIMONDO: It's
exactly the opposite
of what you would think.
All of a sudden, when
it starts sputtering,
you probably want to pull
off and stop doing it.
But Gonzalo's like,
don't be afraid.
Just dump the whole thing in
there and it's actually better.
But I think at the
end of the day,
even if it is
slightly imperfect,
I still can't make a
perfect circle tortilla.
I can't do it, and
I don't know why.
But even if it is
slightly imperfect,
I think it just-- food
tastes better when it
has a story behind it, really.
And Gonzalo, every single
recipe in that book
has a story about it, and some
little moment of education
that gives you a window into
beautiful culture and cuisine
in Mexico.
And I think it's just
so much more satisfying
to sit down at your dinner
table and serve your friends
and family that type of food.
And say, here's the
background of it.
I learned from this
amazing guy's story.
And that, to me, is
what makes it special.
SPEAKER 2: So what would you
say the overall goal is to reach
people with through this book?
What are you hoping
people will get out of it?
GONZALO GUZMAN: I think it's
always been my goal just
to kind of educate
people about food.
And with this book, I think
that's what we're trying to do,
is to educate people more
about what Mexican food is,
and what it takes--
what it takes,
again, to really--
what we do at the
restaurant, and what
I did when I was little.
Again, it kind of
reflects my life,
but at the same times,
Nopalito's life,
because that's what we've
been doing all the time.
So, again, it's just to
educate people and kind of know
more of what we do
at the restaurant.
And just to tell people that
it's not that easy when people
go into the place and
complain about the price
that they're paying.
Because I think
they have that idea
with Chinese food
or Mexican food
that it's always
going to be cheap.
But if you look at the
steps, and the process,
and the ingredients
that we use here,
we use all the fresh ingredients
that we use in this book
or in the restaurant.
They're all local, so we work
with a lot of local farmers.
We go to the farmers markets.
Not myself, but Chef
Laurence goes, because I
don't have enough time.
But we kind of work
together to see.
He'll tell me what's new, and
we will add it to the menu.
And that's kind of like,
again, how I grew up.
Just by using what's in my
backyard, what we had there,
or we'll just grow it wild.
So the end is just I think
we're not trying to--
personally, I'm not
trying to tell everyone,
this is what Mexican food is.
This is the best Mexican book.
I think this is just
what Nopalito is
right now, and part of my life.
And hopefully, people really
appreciate more the restaurant
and enjoy.
And again, this is
just one little piece
of Mexican food from
the South, Veracruz.
So there is so much
more about Mexican food,
and I'm sure there will be
another chef that will say,
oh this is Mexican food now.
But, again, I know
that's going to happen.
But I'm not trying to say that
this is the best Mexican food,
I'm just--
Mexican restaurant, I'm sorry.
STACY ADIMONDO: One thing you
must realize about Gonzalo
is that he couldn't
possibly be more humble,
so I'm here to do
his bragging for him.
And it is the best
Mexican book, by the way.
GONZALO GUZMAN:
[INAUDIBLE], you guys.
No, but honestly, you don't
see any flour tortillas there.
And that's because
I grew up in a place
that there were no
flour tortillas.
I didn't know there
were flour tortillas
until I came to California.
So that wasn't till
I was 15 years old,
that's when I finally
made flour tortillas.
But that wasn't in my head.
That wasn't in my food.
That's all like north of
Mexico, but it's Mexican food.
It is Mexican food, but
it's just a different state,
different place, different--
it's still Mexico
so again it's a little place.
But at the same time it's
what Nopalito is about.
And, again, part of
my life there too.
STACY ADIMONDO: I'm
in the food business,
I write about food for
a living, and I probably
would've thought I knew
something about Mexican cuisine
before I met Gonzalo.
And I sort of felt like, well,
yeah, I don't know everything,
but I sort of get
the general concept.
And something that Gonzalo says,
and we address in the book,
is I think a lot of people
assume it's very heavy.
Everything's cooked in
lard, or deep-fried,
or there's a side
of rice and beans
on the side of everything.
And it's a gut bomb,
and you kind of
like eat it when
you're hungover.
It's like really kind
of silly, and it all
starts with the chips and salsa.
And I very, very, quickly
learned that that was not true.
And of course those foods
are a part of the cuisine,
but it's a very fresh,
regional, varied cuisine.
Something in the book that I
love is a chicken soup recipe.
And there's a big chipotle
chili floating on top of it,
and there's homemade queso
fresco that's cut into cubes
and put at the bottom of
it with chunks of avocados.
So as you dip your
spoon in, there's
this melty piece of cheese
at the bottom of your bowl.
It's just so wonderful, and
so nourishing, and so fresh,
and different.
And I just didn't know
that that existed,
even as a section
of Mexican food,
which sounded so silly
to say in retrospect.
But I think you
know a lot of people
are missing that depth of
understanding the cuisine.
So I think, at least,
I'm extremely honored
to have been able to
help him tell this story,
and to just be educated myself
to walk into a Mexican market
and be able to put some fun
ingredients on the countertop
and just kind of be like,
yeah, I know what I'm doing.
It's so empowering,
and it also just helps
you connect to
this country that's
our neighbors, and our people.
So many of them are so
humble and hardworking,
and they're not going
to brag for themselves.
But I think there's
so much worth
uncovering in taking the time to
go learn about in this cuisine.
So I'm very happy I
got to be part of it.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Me too.
And I've been happy
just to be around people
that believe in me, and then
to help me to get this project.
And now be chef/owner
of a couple restaurants.
but again, there's so
many good cooks there,
but that's what they're missing.
People that believe in them.
And also, then, they need
to educate thier self
with a little more--
by going, at least,
to learn the language.
Because that's one-- that's
something that they--
If we don't do it, then we
cannot really do much here.
Even if we're really
good cooks or we're
really good with anything, we
have to take that extra step.
And that's what I'm
trying to prove, also.
Myself, but to the
people around me.
Kind of show them
that we can do it,
but we also have to
put hard work on it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there one dish that
you'd want everybody who
walks into the restroom to try?
GONZALO GUZMAN: Masa.
So whatever you can
find with masa, try it.
So that's 90% of our menu, 95%.
It's everything.
Again, every dish
that you see there,
we're very proud of doing it.
And I feel like if
it's there, it's
because we felt it's tasty, and
it's good, and it's delicious.
But again, you go
into a restaurant
where we have other
cooks, and sometimes, they
might forget to put
salt [INAUDIBLE].
We try the food every
day, like every morning.
We try all the dishes.
But still, that's still
happens, unfortunately.
Like if I'm not there.
If someone is not
looking at them,
there will be cook that
hopefully we don't have--
but keep that in mind that
with as we can or I can,
I try to just make sure
that everything tastes
really good for everyone.
But, no, I don't really have--
I mean, carnitas is
there just because people
who doesn't love pork.
And then they said it
is the best carnitas,
but again, go and try it
and you make that call.
STACY ADIMONDO: Yeah, carnitas
made the cover for a reason.
Something that I love is seeing
the rotating ceviche offerings
that they have.
Because, again, that's part
of many cultures' cuisine.
You can try a ceviche in a
lot of different restaurants,
but I think I learned
something about Mexican ceviche
from Gonzalo,
trying his versions.
One has grated carrots
in it that I just
thought was so special,
and unique, and unexpected.
He has a lot with--
some of them are red,
and have these sort of
like smoky, oily kind
of sauces with them.
And then others are
bright green, and fresh,
and really vibrant.
And kind of like sour
and puckery in the mouth.
And, of course, his
chips are the best chips.
So it's really just a vehicle--
an excuse to eat chips,
but they're beautiful.
GONZALO GUZMAN:
That's a good point,
because a lot of people, when
they go and have cevivche,
they always have in their
mind, tomato, onions, jalapeno,
and fish.
Overcooked fish.
To me, it's really
fresh everything.
So it's whatever you
can find in-season.
Right now it's asparagus.
Why not just using
that in your ceviche?
If you cook it--
SPEAKER 2: Which
you have right now.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Not anymore.
We just changed that.
No, we still do it.
Sorry.
We still have it.
We just changed-- yeah.
You're supposed to use what
you can grow it yourself,
or what's in season.
And I think, why are you
using something else that
is not really in
season if you have it?
I don't know if it
makes sense, but just
use what you have
instead of trying
to eat tomatoes when they're not
actually really good and sweet.
Just wait until the season,
it's going to come back again.
STACY ADIMONDO: I think there's
a really neat component to when
you go to Nopalito
about trying the dishes,
and the way the
menu is laid out.
Because unlike, I
think, many cuisines,
you don't start with
a lettuce salad,
and then move on to a main
entree, and then eat dessert.
It's sort of like you kind of
choose your own adventure of,
do you want to eat a
combination of street foods?
A very casual meal
in Mexico, I think,
is you eat a taco,
you to gordita.
You eat a number of things that
the street vendors are making
or that you're making at home.
Or you eat these larger plates,
larger-format meals that are--
when Gonzalo was
growing up, kind of more
of a weekend thing, I think.
When they'd have an animal and--
GONZALO GUZMAN: Yeah.
I grew up eating
mostly vegetable,
because meat was
really expensive.
And that's the other reason why
I didn't eat meat that much.
But we will eat the mole
sauce without the chicken,
and it'll be still
really good mole.
But that was kind of the
reason, just because we
wouldn't have access to--
STACY ADIMONDO: Right.
GONZALO GUZMAN: We'll go
and maybe kill an armadillo,
make it into--
Again, we will have to
go out there and hunt it.
That's kind of like--
again, it's [INAUDIBLE],
but that's kind of why.
STACY ADIMONDO: But it's neat
to navigate the menu, I think,
at the restaurant
for the first time.
And sort of say,
we're going to combine
a number of different styles of
these smaller plates and street
foods.
There's very few that I
recognized off first glance.
There was like one taco on
the menu, one quesedilla
on the menu, and everything else
was these neat things that--
I was like, I think I--
do I know what that is?
It's just fun to kind
of go there and do
it one way or the other,
and eat a number of street
foods and masa-based things.
Or then try things
like the carnitas,
or carne asada, or [INAUDIBLE],
some of the braised meats,
and that kind of thing too.
So you should probably just
go on a number of times
to Nopalito and see
what works for you.
GONZALO GUZMAN: We did a
little twist here and there,
just because I know
it's not for everyone.
But salads wasn't
part of my cuisine.
When I grew up, my salad was
a slice of tomato, lettuce,
and lime juice.
But I know here, if I do
that, people will be like,
what is this?
Or something.
Again, for the
restaurants, we're
going to have to have that
option also for the guests too.
So I kind of had to
add a couple of salads
that I didn't grow up with.
They're probably not
really authentic,
but again, we cook for the
guests at the end, too.
So I kind of have to
make it work so it's
a win-win for both sides.
AUDIENCE: So first of all,
my wife and I love Nopalito.
It's our favorite
restaurant in the city.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: We got engaged about
a year ago in San Francisco,
and the first place we walked
to was Nopalito, so we love it.
You learned growing
up how to cook
for yourself or for a family.
How did you learn to scale that
to cooking for two restaurants?
GONZALO GUZMAN: School.
Yeah.
Again, that was-- it's funny.
I always tried to
learn something new,
and actually just
two years ago, I just
graduated from my GED,
high school diploma.
Which, again, I didn't go to
school in Mexico or anything.
Just here, so it was
also at city college.
But math was one
of those classes
that I took two
semesters, because I
wasn't really good at it.
And I'm still not good at it,
but I understand the basics
that I need for cooking.
So that is kind of what
helped me to just scale it up.
Because my co-chef,
which, again, I
learned a lot from him,
and he's part of this book.
Because most of these recipes,
we worked them together
with Jose Ramos.
But that was his challenge
too, like, we need 24 quarts
of salsa for tonight, but
our recipe says 1 quart.
So what do we do?
So again, that pushed myself to
go to school whenever I could
and just to take math.
And that's kind of how I did it.
And same thing goes
for don't now I
have to manage people instead
of just me, and cooking.
Being by myself, cooking for the
people and being on the line.
So I knew now that I
needed to work with people,
and that's another challenge
working in a restaurant,
is managing.
So funny enough, I took one
semester of psychology too,
just--
I don't know, but I
felt like that will--
And again, but going back
to the question, yes,
and I went to school
for basic math
that you probably
already understand.
But just using that as--
AUDIENCE: So I've always
wanted to go to Nopalito,
but I have these
little rugrats that
hang out with me all the time.
Do you feel like your
restaurant has options
that are accessible for kids,
or if not kids, people that
have a less-adventurous palate?
What would you recommend?
GONZALO GUZMAN: Well,
there's always rice and beans
and cheese quesedillas for kids.
But I have two kids.
I have a boy and a girl.
Myself, I push them
to eat anything.
So if they come
with me, honestly,
it's like, here, you
eat some ceviche.
You eat some [INAUDIBLE].
But we have the options of
rice, beans, cheese quesedilla,
side of chicken.
Things that we kind
of know they're--
STACY ADIMONDO:
Well, and I think
some of the dishes that
maybe sound like they're
going to be complicated or spicy
actually have a sweet side too.
So like mole, I couldn't
imagine a kid not liking mole,
like licking their
fingers and making a mess.
I think some of the
soups are really fun.
There's a soup that has--
it sort of looks like--
I kind of think of it
as the Mexican ramen.
It's got noodles,
and chicken, and--
GONZALO GUZMAN: Which is
not on the menu right now.
STACY ADIMONDO: Not
on the menu right now.
But there's this fun
stuff, and it's colorful.
I find that the
restaurant is often
filled with families and kids.
I think it's a real
community that is loyal to
and loves Nopalito.
And it's definitely kind
of come one, come all menu.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Chips and guac.
I mean, kids love that.
I start by that, and then
I think-- slowly I've
seen families that
have been coming
to the restaurant for
now a few years already.
When kids will just go
and order rice and beans,
and little by little,
parents started pushing them
with something else.
And now they're like,
oh, I love your ceviche.
I'm like, okay.
I think it's a great
first opportunity for you
to have your kids try that.
And some of them get
addicted, actually.
They start liking it.
You'll see they like it more
than you will, probably.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So speaking of the
next generation,
what are your future plans?
Are there are going
to be more Nopalitos?
What else are you going to do?
No, no more Nopalitos.
I think there's one Nopalito,
or now, is kind of two.
But those two make one.
Definitely, I don't think
there will be another Nopalito
restaurant.
We're not trying
to build a chain.
That's what I think--
my partner is right
here, actually
will tell you that too.
But definitely, there
is a things in my head.
Hopefully, trying
to think of another
place where we can do
Mexican/California food.
Kind of mix not really Mexican,
because I feel like this one
is Mexican food authentic
as much as we can.
But I kind of want to get
into that of like maybe--
I don't know, different concept
of mixing California, which
have European and
French, and all this.
But being Mexican ingredients
based off that place.
But, again, that's just
in the head right now.
There is nothing that
is happening yet.
But, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The idea is
of another cookbook?
GONZALO GUZMAN: No.
STACY ADIMONDO: What about
the other half of the recipes
that you mentioned?
GONZALO GUZMAN:
Oh, they're there.
They're in the restaurant.
Oh, no.
I don't think so,
but you never know.
So I'm pretty open to whatever.
STACY ADIMONDO: Well, and
I think the cookbook just
becomes a tool.
It's a conversation
starter, I think.
And that's something a
lot of chefs get very--
They want to have everything
be perfect with their book,
and they want to make sure
everybody covers it and what
not
But I think this book
just has its own spirit
of communal education,
sharing, getting the word out.
Gonzalo kind of spreads the love
in the book, and he's not like,
me, me, me.
My food.
It's sort of like,
this region in Mexico,
or, the people who work
with me, or just, you
should know this
about our culture.
So I think the exciting thing
about the book coming out
is just that it gives
another platform
to talk about all this
beautiful background and story
that I think a lot of
people don't know about
and should hear.
GONZALO GUZMAN:
Yeah, but it's true.
I'm not really
inventing anything new.
All these things, someone
is making them in Mexico.
I'm just trying to make
it work for San Francisco,
and using what's around here.
But, again, you see
carnitas-- and I'm not
saying this is the only
place you're going to see it.
You go to Mexico and you're
going to see all different--
what we're doing is
just the techniques,
and fixing little
things here and there.
Making it just taste
better, even if possible.
So that's what it's about.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
Well, with that,
thank you guys both.
STACY ADIMONDO: Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: And thank
you everyone else
for coming and joining us.
STACY ADIMONDO: Thank you, guys.
GONZALO GUZMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]